are you touring around are you yeah
sorry I'm wearing we start touring our
first show is November 7th we're doing
the Eric Andre show live
oh wow didn't like to talk show live and
I just throw a bunch of food is
basically like a Gallagher shell I'm
just throwing food at people the entire
time this he came up to me in New York
and he was like hey man I'm a huge fan
actually been to your live show um your
penis has been in my mouth and I was
like excuse me
apparently I get naked at the show and I
what I did I jumped in the audience we
played that you just and he had his
mouth open and he said for a second like
the tip of my penis went in the
beginning of his mouth cuz he was like
what the UH saw just like oh man that's
crazy well hey great meeting you man I
didn't know where to go from there the
guy gave me a [ __ ] I wanted to be
polite that is one of the first times in
history penis and mouth preceded
handshake yeah and what's your name yeah
yeah good for you Eric you're living off
off the grid because yes here we have
time for one question
um this is fun isn't it fun this is
great I'd go forever I just keep going
I'm gonna live forever are you gonna go
outside on TV wouldn't that be cool
isn't that no nevermind sorry like a
dork shorter you know what that is you
know what that I think that's gonna be
out of depression just it would be like
whoa that I get I always thought it was
funny the ice I'm not even gonna yeah I
got a guy I gotta join you are weird
like a dark corner we're just like a
bumper carring into the this isn't
helping anybody you know what I take
that as a compliment to say I'm so
comfortable I'm gonna say my suicide
material sure I can feel the audience is
just in a frenzy over this there's all
but the beep-beep-beep truck backing up
sound from the audience right now
they're now on the set of The Mentalist
they are not here every grade of
Mentalist was shot in front of a live
studio audience just so people could be
like broody haha scratching your temples
during the I don't know what they've
been of an applause like they're like be
charmed by an Australian oh just sighs
oh let's do one question Eric uh have
you ever feared for your life yes I had
a gun put in my face in Providence Rhode
Island which as you know is the anus of
America shots fired
I was outside of Lupo's I was all drunk
lupus is like a rock venue seen it rock
show and this group of like
twelve-year-old wannabe thugs and tray
like pre-pubescent thugs came up to me
and they were like yo man you think we
can get up in that concert and I was
like I'm probably not without a ticket
and the ringleader was like what if I
just shot up in there and then I was
like well then yeah am I am I supposed
to be answering this question ha ha ha
and then he goes what if I just shot you
and he took out a little pistol and put
it like right in my eyeball and I pooped
my pants uh and then he was just like ha
ha and his friend was just like let's
get out of here they just ran off into
the sewer miss like a Michael Jackson
video video and then the guitar player
from the first band came walking up and
he's rubbing his neck he's like uh I was
like hey man dude what time it is and
he's like ah I wouldn't know what time
it is but these little kids just punched
me in the throat and stole my phone
I was like they put a gun in my face and
then we high-fived and it freeze-frame
and the credits for Degrassi junior high
and that's what I knew I was pregnant